I have to say something right now and I
was gonna save it for another podcast
but I can't I'm sorry but since you're
here and Gilbert you guys are here
something happened to me last week that
was very humiliating for me so I was at
the Comedy Store with Niki Youssef and
he goes here I'm gonna I'm gonna go do a
show at the Laugh Factory can you drop
me off okay you know what I'm gonna go
get a Greenblatt so I'll just Park so I
parked my car and I with Nick Youssef
and I we walk into the lab factory and
two people came up to me and goes
where's your ticket
then I go why yeah you need a ticket or
get out the staff yeah I go what kids yo
don't you people don't feel bad I saw
Katt Williams get rejected from the
caroline's Christmas party and he was in
a full-length fur coat and the girl was
like what are you on the list
yeah and she's just brand new these
people they hire these clubs it don't
feel bad he that happened to him at the
Laugh Factory - that's what their point
was it happened to Kat but that's not
the point
no that's not the point okay sorry girl
right is if you're working at a comedy
club in LA I'm just I'm not okay let me
just say this I know I'm not Chris Rock
I know I'm not louis c.k i know where
i'm at all right I'm at the bottom fine
Bobby Lee you are no wonder girls of
music video alright but when it comes to
the Comedy Store and The Laugh Factory
in The Improv here in LA since I've been
here for 20 years and I've played those
clubs for 20 years and I'm friends with
the owner of the club I've been around
the country with the owner of the club I
know every single comic that performs
there I'm on the payroll right that you
should don't you think that they should
know who I am or now or at least
whoever you put up to the front to deal
with people coming in the door should at
least be well versed with who's who
yeah so that when it yeah it's part of
your job don't apply for a job at a
comedy club without doing your research
to see who comedians are or at least
just especially the ones who perform at
your club yeah what did you say to them
or who's in the marquee down the street
you know what I mean like it doesn't do
well I said it's so embarrassing but did
I go on Bobby Lee he goes no I don't
even know the name cuz I've never been
in the situation song playing untie your
toes I'm blushing I'm sweating didn't
recognize Nick Youssef no they asked for
his hug and he was on the list right
yeah he's on the list right so Nick owes
my ID I don't I'm performing here and
I'm like and then I just kind of let up
the building I just left
oh my god and then I told the doorman
when you I thought they just asked for
my Daisy yeah you know they're new and I
and then I texted everyone I knew nice
texted [ __ ] Julia Eric Griffin a
bunch of people Johnny Sanchez going
they wouldn't let me in the Laugh
Factory
and then I just said I'll never go back
there again damn over one person's - yes
yes over one person that's the point
okay that's the [ __ ] point of the
whole thing let me see something right
now okay that's how people learn okay
and also this the same thing happened to
me I told you the story but in Seattle
oh that's right at the parlor live oh
that bad have I told that story here on
the podcast yeah
it's been a while in a while I'll say
the story again I do a show at the
parlor live and I'm sorry but it's not a
big room I sold that every show I'm
sorry I have to say it sold out every
[ __ ] show
okay I do one show kill it uh-huh go to
my hotel room
shower I'd go back to the second show
and I walk into the club and the doorman
puts his arm out grabs me it pulls me
out of the club
we're sold out right and I and and every
comic that I tell this dude they said
why don't you just say that you're the
headliner no no Bob look like that you
didn't have to tell them wrong the
headliner is everybody on staff should
know who the headliner is yeah yeah I
know what their picture looks like
exactly and also this is also fun for me
then when he puts his arm around me I'm
like you like because this is about to
turn into something there's a
confrontation that's gonna happen and
I'm gonna see what I'm gonna do so what
I do is I go I kind of pushed him aside
and I will compute a look at the club
yeah John without saying anything was he
bigger than you way bigger he was at
this American Indian dude get a long
hair right and he as I'm walking in the
club he's now in front of me walking
backwards oh whoa whoa you deaf man then
he finally stops wearing my tracks and
he goes so I leave meanwhile I'm
supposed to go and as I'm walking on the
club oh yeah all right I'm leaving but
tell Ruben cancel the show because why
cuz I'm the headliner and I just leave
right and didn't do the show no wait
Mike no of course I'm did the show but
I'm like milking it right I'm walking
away and then he's now looking at like
the pictures he's freaking out oh no
he's that oh my god that is yeah
whatever and he's just getting angry why
don't you tell me and I'm screaming that
right so then I go up on stage I go back
I ever get in the club and then when I
get off its
there's people in the green room that
I've never seen before you're talking
about the guy that owns the whole
building you mean like like investor you
know man
they're all there and they're all on it
was so so we fire them and I go no I
feel guilty right so then I had I spent
24 hours begging to get that guy's job
back yeah so it could have been as
simple as this I'm the headliner I just
walked in and did my show and nothing we
got I had to do this complete [ __ ]
chaos and it's so fun to do you know I
mean so with this Laugh Factory thing
I'm never going back until somebody
apologizes what you don't get it I mean
I do you do get it right you're the
queen that's really good for the respect
nobody really likes he he loves to make
a bigger fuss about it
trust me make a point beyond that he
wants people to learn a lesson
he loves the drama it's not drama
that's a weird way of saying it I enjoy
a spectacle are you so much we go and
let me tell you something once again
like I don't like this I like that a lot
[Music]